siga the latest we mostly focus our
attention on security regarding civil
aviation the council clearly adopted the
agreement of member states or new rules
on european aviation safety agency we
are focusing on two aspects
strengthening the approach to regulation
based on risk and performance we will
have the first europe-wide regulation
for a safety integration of drones into
european air space as regards aviation
the council has authorized us to start
negotiations on aviation agreement with
armenia on the passenger ship safety
package today we really adopted a
general approach for two of these
proposals with a progress report
presented for the third one in Transport
Security there was a broad agreement on
the importance of the UN Security
Council resolution of September and the
momentum it will generate we discussed
how to work forward a common European
approach in this area we looked into the
investment needs of Europe transport a
new innovative ways of financing today
is also an official launch of a new
innovative instrument that we define
together with the IB to address the
needs of clean vehicle to support the
efforts of cities to introduce new green
public transportation especially buses